I'm sitting here with Nick Cartman he's
one of our front-end web developers
thanks for sitting with me absolutely so
tell me a little bit about refactoring
what's one way that you might go about
it so we're factoring is the process by
which you take a piece of code and make
it more readable and more maintainable
without changing its functionality so
that means you might want to break up
large functions or complicated functions
without changing the way that they're
accessed by the outside world or the
other components of your application got
it so basically you're taking the
organization which will say in this case
is already alright and you're taking the
big unmaintainable or difficult to
understand functions and you're breaking
them up but it's important not to change
things in terms of the way the
components interact with each other
right precisely this makes sure that you
increase readability maintainability and
ease of working with your code but
without breaking the contract that you
have between you and the other
developers you're working with and the
contract that the pieces of the app have
with each other as well exactly
awesome that sounds like a good method
thanks for sitting with me absolutely